the side does that mean black uh white
sorry only has one force reply if you
can't move the knight out of the way
then you have to you have to defend it
with the queen you're walking into a
self pin on this diagonal the white
knight is paralyzed now never being able
to move white bishop paralyzed defending
it he's dropped back with his knight
right back okay okay but
bishop comes in and now okay we do have
to see the character yeah let's go back
to the players this is just winning now
for magnus carlsen he's allowed black's
bishop to penetrate and
what's he doing he can't even take this
black rook let's keep an eye on the
players is lev neroni and shaking his
head
yes
he knows his queen was almost trapped he
had to move it using the white knight at
shelter but look magnus he's just
merciless pushing poor uh pushing pawns
forward throwing them forward with
abandon attacking this bishop and now if
this bishop moves you know what he's
going to do he's just going to push
forward again this knight is pinned and
if if the rook ever drops off remember
the queen is trapped
this is this is just sensational player
yeah absolutely fantastic uh model play
from magnus carlsen torture by bishops
horns queens yeah all of them torture by
i mean i have never ever seen a
situation like this where the queen is
on one of those two either e.t square on
the d2 square which is like trapped